where the standard model is precisely
what classifier is all these particles
which from which we can construct the
whole world actually the standard model
contains essentially all these quarks
these electrons that constitute the
atoms all their other elementary
particles that one can construct out of
them all day not of ample collisions and
it contains describes the force which
are we through them and that is
essentially the recipe because the
forces are also transmitted by some
element Barkley particles on which have
my submission on that mal photon has no
masters which gives the so-called week
the interaction given mass and
essentially there are three kinds of
interaction which are included in the
standard model the electromagnetic
interaction the weak interaction which
are responsible in particular for the
disintegration radioactive decay and
these two were united in a theory that
make a very deep use of how the early
which was done in a quite general frame
and the standard model contains in
addition strong interaction which also
our interaction between object which
inside the nucleus but which are
responsible for essentially the cohesion
of these nuclear these are the strong
interaction which are not explained by
our theory but by something different
which actually is essentially related to
your theory by something which is called
thats a duality let's say it's the
opposite now the opposite of something
is not necessarily
this thing so that it is so these are
the three type of interaction which
formed these particles that we know
today that are all together and getting
a mass now with this this Bo zone that
was discovered or guided by the sea of
them which gives this C which permeates
the universe and and there is another
interaction which we feel every day
which is gravitationally let an abject
fall and it falls then why the planets
turn around the earth and why everything
like that works and that is also a
theory but for the moment it is not
included in the standard model it is
something apart we know it very well
it's the first thing that was known it
was redeveloped by Einstein and
generalized by Einstein is called the
bad name but it's called general
relativity that was in the beginning of
the 20th century and so that is very
well known but it has its difficulties
and not I don't know if you want to
enter into that that's more complicated